Prime Minister you're just about to go
to meet some child refugees in a school
do you feel vindicated by an approach
that says that those refugees should
stay here in the region when some have
criticized you back home for not saying
more should come to the United Kingdom
well I think it's very important as the
UK government has done since the
beginning of the Syrian crisis that we
do predominantly provide aid in the
region so we can support people so
they're close to home so when we do see
a peaceful solution to the conflict in
Syria and people are able to return home
they're able to do that but but while
they are refugees in countries like
Jordan which I'll be visiting visitings
and refugees today we actually prove our
helped provide education and training so
they have the skills they need when they
finally return home so the kids who stay
here in the region I think it's
important that we support of course
we're taking refugee children into the
United Kingdom but the view we took was
that it was important to ensure that
those we bring to the United Kingdom
those who are most vulnerable who
particularly require the help and
support that we can give in the UK but
for the majority we can help far more
refugees by the age we're putting into
the region our total aid as a result of
the Syrian crisis it's 2.3 billion
pounds we've been the second biggest
bilateral donor overall that means we
have been providing food water medical
supplies and yes education and training
to young people to refugees to help them
with their futures on Saudi Arabia isn't
it just the reality that you are not
going to raise with King Salman the
issue of jailed dissidents the issue of
the use by the Saudis of cluster bombs
made in Britain against Yemen well you
have no difficulty in raising hard
issues with those that we meet with
whether bearding Saudi Arabia or
elsewhere around the world what matters
is that we have the relationship of
engagement that enables us to do that
but we will also be talking about the
very important relationship the UK has
with Saudi Arabia an important
relationship yes in terms of trade but
also in terms of security our
cooperation the saudis cooperation with
us has helped to save lives in the UK
is there a pattern developing in your
foreign trips people are relating it to
brexit are we downplaying human rights
concerns with your visits to Saudi
Arabia to Turkey where's this strong
British tradition of standing up for
human rights the strong British
tradition of standing up for human
rights is there the stronger Jewish
tradition of standing up for British
national interest is there I want to see
the United Kingdom as a truly global
Britain outward looking around the world
trading around the world yes a good
continuing deep partnership with the
European Union but also trading and
working with others around the whole of
the globe that's what we will be doing
in future that's what I'm working on
yes it's about trade that's about jobs
back home in the United Kingdom but it's
also about our security security for the
UK and us working with others to
maintain security around the world
so Prime Minister you mention that
phrase truly global nation in the future
but we're standing here in Jordan
currently we have a free trade
arrangement with Jordan through the EU I
mean the risk is we lose that so it's
not about being more global how do you
protect what we've got already in terms
of how global we are no it will be
possible for us to continue trade
arrangements with countries where we've
previously had them through the EU once
we're outside the European Union but it
also means that we can negotiate our own
REIT raid arrangements with various
parts of the world I think that's going
to be important to us we want to have a
deep and special partnership continuing
with the European Union but yes we want
to build our relationships with old
friends and new allies alike around the
world in terms of your strategic
objectives before roughly this point
we're now through the gate of article 50
you wanted pre negotiations we didn't
get them you wanted parallel
negotiations on the exit deal and
article 50 they've said no you talked
about No Deal doesn't look like anybody
believes that threat haven't your key
strategic aims not been hit as we
trigger article 50 no you're quite wrong
I mean let's first of all let's look at
the whole question of the where we end
up at the end of this negotiation have
we look will we have looked at both
withdraw and the future relationship
that's what's important that's what I'm
that's what I'm asking for and that's
what I believe increasingly we will we
will see
you will see from the European Union
various people have commented that they
think we should get on to looking at
that future relationship soon and we
will do that what's important is that
when we leave the EU people know what
the future relationship is it's common
sense it's pragmatic for people it's
pragmatic for businesses and I believe
that's what we'll be working for I think
it's what both sides will be working for
on No Deal in your Lancaster House
speech the talk around that was turning
us into a kind of singapore-style Haven
after that Boris Johnson says actually
no deal is perfectly okay and then in
the article 50 letter it there is this
sort of implied security threat to seem
slightly chaotic and so what we've said
is very clear that is that we expect to
get and we want to get the best possible
deal for the United Kingdom
I believe that's possible because it
won't just be a good deal for us it will
be a good deal for the rest of the
European Union on security issue it's a
very practical reason for raising it in
the letter we're currently a member of
certain programs certain systems around
Europe that help us to cooperate on
exchanging information about terrorists
but also about criminals once we leave
the EU our membership of those systems
lapses so it's right that as part of the
negotiations we'll be talking to the
European Union about how we can continue
with those arrangements it's in our
interest it's also in theirs if you're
confident that no deal can be better
than a bad deal
why not publish some evidence
independent evidence to prove that
as the committee suggests today well I'm
very clear that we will be working to
get the best possible deal for the UK as
I said in the article 50 letter I set
out what would be a No Deal situation
but I also said I don't think that's in
anybody's interest we will be working to
get the best possible deal in the
British national interest
I believe that deal will be good for the
European Union as well I believe both
sides will be working to ensure we have
a good positive deep and special
partnership going into the future
can you clarify that you accept what the
European Council suggested which is that
the final deal will be done as a third
country status under you know a
unanimous vote with everyone having a
veto that there's there's obviously a
legal situation in terms of how the
European Union can conduct trade
negotiations I'm clear that by the point
at which we leave
European Union it's right that everybody
should know what the future arrangement
the future relationship that future
partnership between US and the European
Union will be that's the sensible thing
it's a pragmatic way to look at this and
I believe that's what we'll do and you
still think that can be done within two
years yes okay just lastly do now do
admit that now this judgement that
people made a judgment but your
decisions on leaving the single market
and on leaving the customs union this is
now on you this was your judgment and if
it goes wrong it's the responsibility of
prime minister may the British people
chose to leave the European Union I've
set out very clearly the European Union
has made clear that the membership of
the single market effectively means
membership of the European Union people
have decided not to be members of the
European Union so our relationship with
the single market will be a different
one in future but that doesn't mean it
can't be a really good trade
relationship that will now enable
our firms to have free access to the
single market and continue to trade in
ways that they have done in the past